didier
[ __ ] ma fille tu fais chier à je suis
allé deux là impeccable et qu'est ce que
c'est laurent dix ans je suis le chef de
file des gens qui ne comprennent pas
cette des chemises sont résistants et je
suis rentré dans la veine prendre le
maquis ce soir à la france gronde
tu ne t'en rends pas compte tirer les
jeunes enfants prochaine bien aurélie
dupont est ce que vous êtes mytho non je
vous êtes schizo c'est bientôt
est ce que vous êtes parano un petit peu
ouais à l'opéra c'est tellement
maintenant ça va mieux avoir un petit
peu par luc mazaud forcément un peu pour
faire ce boulot là elle fait la
trentaine il resterait toi devant une
barre pendant des heures les chaussures
en fait je vous êtes sado
pas encore pas encore à ce qui veut dire
tout peut arriver en même temps techcite
à l'infernal je vous êtes exhibo vous
aimez bien au premier tour devant la
fenêtre je pas forcément ça met un peu
exhib oui forcément je dansais un
s'ennuie ou d'être de se dévoiler en
penser un peu les fibres est ce que vous
êtes géronto ah oui le rapport par
rapport à tout le monde tout comme moi
pour avoir moi aussi c'est quand on aime
les gens plus âgés visage et comme
d'usagé le visage et ça dépend entre 50
ans de plus et dix ans de plus ils ont
de plus pourquoi pas ouais vision de
plus pourquoi pas vous avez quel âge
j'ai bientôt 28 ans a fait 38 parce que
vous êtes quand je dis porno c'est parce
que vous regardez cassettes pornos
souhaite porno vos gardes
je veux pas de cassettes ça n'arrivait 2
ap et de regarder ça me fait ça amuse
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup rire
à bord c'est du travail j'ai regardé
comme tout le monde quoi qui n'est pas
rien n'affirme pas en regardant bien sûr
le porno ici la femme c'est à dire que
le scénario est toujours le même alors
ouais pas tellement et comme dans la vie
on l'a tous vu à ces normes sont pas
toujours le même nombre s'est passé et
je faisais de disco
je vous demande de vous arrêter je me
demande de vous arrêter je vous demande
de vous